[Applause]
we're here on the rooftop of drumfield
sports center where the council has just
completed a an over 1.5 million pound uh
boost to the Leisure Center and what
we've been doing is we've accessed a
grant from the government through the
public sector decarbonization scheme to
install as you can see behind me over
sorry 239 solar panels we've also
installed some air SOS heat pumps as
well as several other improvements uh
including cavity wall insulation LED
lighting different sorts of heaters down
in the Sports Hall and it's really
fantastic way of doing our bit as a
district council to tackle climate
change so one of the key things we're
doing here it's not just about time and
change it's all about long-term
sustainability for these facilities it's
a time when there's 2 000 pools across
the country looking at facing closure
because the running costs have got so
high especially energy costs and all the
work that we're doing here it's a
win-win win for the climate and win for
keeping it open and we're saving
thousands of pounds every year on
running this facility